hey what's up guys my name is the Chino
and welcome to episode 93 of game
programming so we're gonna talk about a
bit of a I guess more advanced method to
do AI but of course the thing is you
can't really measure AI and being like
okay this is the advanced way to do it
no no that's not how it works because
what basically the way you implement AI
in your game depends on actually what
you want to make the behavior of your
non player characters be right if you
want them to just stand around do
nothing this is absolutely fine you can
see that we've got quite a lot more
quite a lot of mobs here they just like
going around minding their own business
walking around doing nothing standing
around you know occasionally they're
just chillin you know and this is
absolutely fine that's probably too many
of them and they are kind of annoying
but for the purposes of this let's um
let's okay let's come over here into in
a minute I'm thinking it doesn't matter
I was thinking um then I might uh I want
something to differentiate the guys by
but that's alright as in because I might
create different guys but we'll see um
where is a where that's one level okay
so what we're gonna talk about now is um
let's maybe take this down in about ten
instead of a hundred because uh hundreds
to me fat tents probably too many let's
take it down to five so will spawn five
dummy boroughs five dummy bras again
that's pretty good right okay so what we
want to do now is um is we're actually
gonna make a new type of AI okay
now that we've covered dummy let's make
another one and we'll call this one will
make it I was actually planning to do it
any different mob just thought we want
as well let us call it who I'm thinking
of a name that would actually describe
its behavior essentially is gonna chase
the player I guess for the player but
it's pretty stupid to doing that so um
we'll just call it chase like because
chaser just implies that it's dumb I
don't know why because like it's not
like it's not a pathfinding I think it's
just dumb I just kind of chase traces
you now this method of AI is uh probably
the most simple but it's also really
effective for the amount of party
to type so again we'll make sure that
the constructor of this chaser mob has
an in X&Y because those are indeed the
spawn locations so we'll do the same the
same thing we did there which is
basically just make sure we convert it
from pixel precision in star precision
so that or rather the other way round
type precision to pixel precision so
that it can place it accordingly and
then in the rent and the render will
just render of course friend render mob
XP YP sprite and flip so all we need to
do and flip is Flip should be 0 what we
should do an accent and that should be
that and that okay whoops okay so if we
go into our dummy here we've got all
this code let's copy and paste that I
know I know a lot of you guys are gonna
be like honest very bad way of doing it
you know I don't care and we might some
of this is different for for moms I
could make it up stick with mega super
class but I don't think I want to bother
so if you're coming here to our where
are we dummy
so dummy and chase are out to AI
characters I guess make sure we sets
Friday culture animators brighter gasp
right just before we render it'll make
sure that it does get the most updated
version every time and let's also make
sure that we create these ones so for
now they'll basically be the same as
dummy right they'll look the same as
dummy right now
that's alright well um okay so x and y
are bad let's make sure that we go
private into XA 0 right and y 0 okay
adèle why are soft yes it is so this is
just the direction stuff okay that's why
this exists this currently has no island
so in other words if i come over here
into our spawn level and i get rid of
new dummy and i add a new chaser at 2055
make sure we import that class obviously
i run this what if i have a bunch of
cars and as you can see they have no
behaviour they just say they're doing
nothing now I'm gonna show you guys a
quick trick okay this is very useful for
development oh look at that we've got a
bunch of errors here I know what that is
by the way that's because um I I hit the
Windows key there to search for stuff
and we are
we haven't handled the windows key in
terms of uh in terms of um because we
only like counting like the first two
hundred cares in the windows K happens
to be like 524 but anyway that's a
rubble do that later
that was a you're not irrelevant if I
open paint.net here quickly
and I actually go to my recent and I
pull up qingchun oh here you can see
that uh well will don't want to each
other if we actually just click on his
purple robe here we can actually get the
hexadecimal color for that which is 470
BBF as you can see so if we grab that
and we go into chaser here we of course
see that we render a mob again this is
the this Cundy the way that it works so
what we can do in random mob obviously
the the problem I guess with random of
that random object an of random up right
now okay what it does is it takes an in
X and in Y it takes an exposition of Y
position a sprite and well whether it's
flipped or not that's dumb but that
doesn't matter the point is um it has no
idea what's rendering this is as far as
far as I can see this bright method
simply um all this is doing right now is
just rendering a sprite okay not really
a mop because we could call this method
to render anything so I'm gonna copy and
paste this and make you get another
round of method that's actually called
render mob and this will actually take
different parameters it will it'll have
mob mob here they won't have a flip
because that's stupid I guess
but um that's what well that's what
it'll have and if you're over here we'll
get rid of this flip card could we
donate it and instead of sprite or
pixels here I'm gonna hit up mob dot
gets sprite but it doesn't have yet dot
pixels again so if we go to entity I
don't think entities are okay they are
for staff sprites so what will make an
entity is a public sprite get sprite and
that will simply else that will simply
return sprite alright pretty simple if
we go back into here
so mom don't guess bright pixels okay so
that and that'll do the same thing so if
we're going to chase let's double check
that this does work let's get rid of
let's put this in here since this is
this is indeed a type of mob and if we
run this let's see if they actually do
random and they don't the crash with a
nullpointerexception so looks like gets
priors probably know just go quite weird
actually I guess some hmm okay let's uh
cuz we do set the sprite don't we
oh we've got to set the sprite so let's
make sure this bride is equal to I guess
we could set it equal to annum sprite I
guess Brian that exists maybe not maybe
that hasn't been created yet let's just
set it to sprites darts dummy okay let's
hit that up okay so we still get a
nullpointerexception huh
I wonder what some wonder what snow are
we rendering this anywhere else I don't
think so that's zero that's 28 why is
that 28 huh I might have forgotten
something let me just quickly check and
all right so let's just um actually
check what's now I don't think it wants
to show us oh I think I might know why I
think because it's getting up to 28
before its hits now let's just see if
they like it what mob girl gets
frightened is and that'll help us some
okay so okay so the sprite isn't all
right now which not sure why
sprite isn't all by default obviously
but it should get said let's just um cut
this out of here and put it into mob
here and make sure I think the only
other explanation would be that mob has
its own sprite okay that's why I'm not
sure why this is here let's get rid of
that that's what's creating the issue
here and let's push this back into
entity so make sure that um obviously
there's probably referring to us correct
right so over here sprite it's not
visible so let's go back to Auntie
and make sure that this is protected I
should have seen the private sign there
and been like oh something's wrong but
long day okay so now if we were on this
let's go back into screen quickly and
get rid of this line that okay we
already did let's run this and see what
we get
okay so this works as you can see so
that's good now what we want to do is if
we go into here and you chase them up
here what we can do now that we've done
this is if we go back into render mob
because we know that this is a chaser
right this is um probably a bad way of
doing this maybe I'm not sure there's a
lot of ways you could do this but the
point is what I'm going to do is I want
to say over here that if color is equal
to that car that we looked at which is
right over here
fossum so the color is Cape we can
actually and make sure you put an FF at
the front because of course when we read
files it does also read the Alpha
channel which is I think the 17th to the
24th bit India in the UM actual number
okay so oh
if color does he called that we can
actually set it to something else so
let's make his robe
I guess dark red here so let's pump up
some more red maybe this way and we'll
drop this a bit that's a nice car
alright so in other words what we're
saying here is that if if the color of
the robe is this but I'll hang on one
thing we have to do is say that if um if
mob is an instance of a chaser so that
sort of only does it for the chaser and
color is that will and color is out will
actually change the color so make sure
you have some brackets around here okay
and make sure you import chess off all
right so what that's gonna do is it's
gonna say that hey if the mob that we're
rendering is a chaser right check for
which color equals this color which is
the purple and change it to another
color right so what's going to do is
it's gonna say that again if this is a
chaser mob and the color equals purple
let's change the call to red so if we
run this what you'll see
is it all of that we've got a red
version of sprite and the reason I did
this was because um once we once we
start this is just a quick way to
basically differentiate between a
surprise okay because if we go if we
come over here and and add a new let's
just say I knew dummy you know if they
were the exactly the same we wouldn't be
able to we wouldn't be able to tell
which um just put this here we wouldn't
be able to tell which is which but now
that we've got you know as you can see
we can assist that the red ones are
traces and those ones are just dummies
okay and we can clearly see that because
the College of French adds them okay so
that is that's gonna wrap up this
episode of gaming
next time we'll actually take a look at
at the AI for these chases I just really
wanted to clear this side of this
differentiation out as well as making
that new random mob method so yeah hope
you guys enjoyed this episode again
programming you did play so the like
button towards it likes one a video per
day 300 likes two videos per day I'm
sure you guys are used to that but I'll
um I'll see you guys next time goodbye
you